Next with tin and lead
solder, they fuse a
threaded neck ring to
the bottom edge.
This ring attaches the
bonnet to the helmet's
breastplate, which
bolts to the collar of
the diver's dry suit.
Then they solder a base
to the face plate
opening. Like all the
helmets components, it's
made of red brass,
which is more durable
than standard brass due
to its higher copper
content. Through a
template.
They drill holes into a
banana shaped brass
exhaust tube.
It enables the divers
exhaled air to exit the
helmet. They solder the
exhaust to the bonnet,
positioning the non
perforated end over a
hole near the diver's
mouth and the perforated
end at the rear.
This directs air
bubbles behind the diver
so as not to obstruct
the view.
Then they solder on the
remaining components,
including three window
bases.